hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played in 1929 at the
Kazan city Championship Junior section
on the white end samsonov and he's
playing against the 16 year old Rasheed
niezmatina 15 move game how did this one
end so fast well
you got a sharp opening
Vienna Gambit
sharpens further with D5
his early tension is resolved somewhat
with f takes E Knight takes e and on
move 5 we have Knight F3
if white exchanges Knights
what would be your assessment of this
position
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video who would you prefer to be and why
maybe give it 30 seconds
okay
the computer prefers black here white to
move but prefers black
reading is around minus 0.5 or 0.6 but
forget about the numbers for a second
what is it about this position that
leans more towards black
there are a couple things that stick out
to me one are the Bishops for black both
doors are already opened white cannot
say the same
in two
note the pawns and the squares they're
controlling
this guy whites E5 Pawn is controlling
F6
and Black's Pawn is controlling F3 why
am I drawing special attention to F3 and
F6 well what pieces have been exchanged
so far
Black's King Knight
and White's Queen Knight
e Pawns bother
King Knights
this guy in other words no longer has
his favorite Square black does not
experience this issue
okay
in this game it's simply Knight F3 black
continues to develop increases the
pressure on C3 freezes this Pawn can't
move straight away
light wants to get rid of this guy Queen
E2
from here Bishop takes Knight black
wants to maintain this guy black also
wants to move back wants to address this
threat
to chop away on e4 and get the move back
if you're taking
uh on C3 with the Knight exchanging
Knights
white gets to recapture and you have to
react to this threat
Bishop takes Knight in this game
black gets to continue to develop
Bishop G4
this is where white starts to go wrong
this point here
is not weakened because of this last
move and white goes in for a pawn grab
what's considered a better idea is to
continue to develop with Bishop A3
stopping kingside castles and also with
an ion queenside castles
now when I saw this in preparing for
this video this idea to go for Queen
side castles with no bee Pawn around I
was
a little like do I want to go in that
direction is it really safe
if you have a similar feeling I I get
that do know that you have another
option
a little bit earlier or further back
right here instead of taking with the B
Pawn you could always take with the
d-pawn and go Bishop F4 Queen side
castles
in any case
in our game instead of Bishop A3 we have
Queen B5 check
C6
Queen takes B7
Bishop takes Knight so white is going
all in for this material
and now the white king is feeling some
pressure here the key King side Defender
the Knight
is no longer around it's no longer
controlling the H4 Square so the black
queen
has an I on that point
in this game Queen takes Rook is played
considered best is to chop the bishop
and we even see it one move later
this idea to get rid of the bishop is
considered best
why did white maybe not want to take the
bishop it's because of this
Queen H4 move what are your options now
what would be White's options at this
point well
if you step up to E2 there's only two
options
if you step up to E2 and that's going to
turn out pretty bad
after check King here that would be May
and after King here we could take this
Pawn with check
and then take a timeout to Castle this
Rook will not be going anywhere it will
soon be one
try to save it there's Queen F2 with the
fork
so that's probably a line that scares
White
however
considered best is King here allowing
this fork and in this position
it's actually close to an evenish
evaluation
black now has to come back to defend
against this check has to block the
check
if you're stepping up there's going to
be mate for white
this position even though black is up a
rook
it's only a hair better
for black this Knight is going to be one
white has an extra Pawn white has the
bishop pair
in any case this is considered best to
take the bishop and enter that line
there that imbalance position but in
this game it's Queen takes Rook
what do you play here considered best is
to Castle make sure the king is nice and
cozy make sure the Rook is around to
defend the Knight and that way the queen
is ready to go all in
this game though it is Bishop takes G2
eliminating that two-point Pawn
eliminating
this defensive move G3
so if black tries Queen H4 right now G3
would hit and black would have no better
than to Simply fall back here to defend
against Queen takes Knight
in a different situation with the black
king tucked away
there's this idea to take on G3 and say
huh you're in a pin
not here though the timing is just not
right so
this is considered best second best is
the move played in the game Bishop takes
G2
and from here
we have uh terrible move as it turns out
played by white
what was what would happen if Bishop
takes Bishop is played in this position
Queen H4 check
King here and the suggestion is to flick
in this check
pull the king back to the center and
then take a timeout to Castle and even
though black is down a full Rook
how valuable are these two pieces they
have to be worth more than 12. this
queen is
stuck in the corner we're ready to get
some material back checks maybe a fork
one thing I questioned in preparing for
this video is why it was important
with this specific line
to First insert Queen G4 check before
castles
the reason why that's important is
because if you Castle first
white could play Bishop A3 not only
attacking The Rook but giving this King
an Escape Route towards the queen side
if you try to check in this position
he's hanging a right
you're not getting at this King
Queen takes Bishop
Rook D1 defends everything white would
be winning
so a nice little additional check to
First flick in ensuring this King stays
stuck in the center
castling privilege is long gone
you're stuck in the center you will not
run towards the queen side
all right in this game
Bishop E2 is played
Can you spot Black's next move
feel free to pause the video
okay
this is a Checkmate in five it ends in a
flashy way
a favorite of many coming up Queen H4
check these are all only moves here for
white
you gotta go to eat you gotta go to D1
and Knight F2 check
King back
and double check King back
Queen sacrifice and normally the
smothered mate happens with the white
king or a king in the corner but not
here
Knight F2
and that's the ball game so a 15 mover
white got too greedy there look at the
final position
smothered mate for white the queen
watches from the corner
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below I hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away that's
all for now take care bye